in the in the most basic sense
conducting is the art of organizing
music through a kind of pantomime using
your hands your face and your eyes in
order to shape and control and deliver a
musical performance that requires a lot
of people when there are a lot of people
on stage each of whom knows his or her
part are terrific musicians they have to
have some sense of coordination because
the piece that they're doing involved so
many different moving parts you need one
person to try to keep it all together so
there's a basic traffic cop part of
being a conductor the most obvious place
where conductors are needed is in an
opera pit so you have the conductor in
the Opera pit you've got musicians in a
pit that's the orchestra then you maybe
have an offstage band you got a chorus
onstage got a bunch of people in
costumes
shouting each other running around going
crazy you have to keep all of this
machine it's a very complex machine
keep it going where everybody comes into
the right place gets out at the right
place everything happens in an organized
way that's the traffic cop part of
conducting that's why so many great
conductors come out of the Opera pit
because that's the place where
coordination of things is very important
the other area where conducting is very
important is in music that doesn't in a
way seem very easily understood so let's
say a complicated piece in the 20th
century would think of the Rite of
Spring by Stravinsky where it's complex
rhythmically there are a lot of things
happening at the same time but not in
the same place let's say the fourth
symphony of Charles Ives which has many
different rhythms like a geological
layer one on top of the other so you
know how do you keep track of your part
well you need someone there who again is
organizing the traffic cop part of it
but the traffic cop part of it is the
most basic aspect of conducting and it's
needed just for efficiency's sake in
other words you could there have been
histories in the Soviet Union for
example there was a very famous
Orchestra that had no conductor that did
some of the per coffee of premieres we
a communist idea you know was a
collective there would be no boss no
owner no no guy in front who was going
to tell them what to do so it was a
collective experience first of all
everything took 16 times as long to
prepare because they couldn't agree they
argued and debated and disputed and so
one point of view never won you know was
kind of a mishmash and Prokofiev
describes these endless rehearsals of
trying to figure out who is right who is
keeping the right rhythm who was with
the other person and so he wished
suddenly for a conductor to help it out
Orpheus today is very fine ensemble that
works without a conductor but it needs
much more rehearsal time so there's an
efficiency issue and then finally the
most sophisticated part of it probably
is an interpretive issue so you need
someone who comes in with a point of
view who shapes in arguments like a
director in a play you could ask the
same thing got a bunch of these actors
they come out on stage there's Hamlet
that's Romeo and Juliet and they know
their lines they're literate what are
you director for but we think they need
a director even though the director is
invisible in this case because it's it's
a different kind of art form the
director is visible now the most
important part is that conducting is
about communication with a bunch of
people about a work of music now there's
a lot of nonsense theater and conducting
a lot of dancing around a lot of Show
and Tell log Hollywood biz which one do
with conducting there's a lot of
marketing personality stuff there's a
lot of fakery in conducting the reason
conductors are always held in suspicion
is because if you're going to the Vienna
Philharmonic or the Berlin Philharmonic
and you're doing a Mozart symphony they
probably don't need a conductor to get
through the piece so the conducting
becomes decorative supplemental it
becomes a cult of personality so in in a
certain limited arena there's a log of
bogus conducting you know someone plays
the piano plays the violin you know it
sounds out of tune and they don't play
very well you know it's hard to fake
pianists you know you can put the pedal
down but you really can't get away with
not being able to play
so conducting is a little more elusive
because it doesn't appear to make any
sound
I think there's a big misunderstanding
some people think well the composer
wrote the music well that's true and
there's a score but depending when the
score was written the number of
indications of what to do are very few
so in the 18th and 19th centuries you
know first of all before conducting was
a professional conductor he didn't exist
till somewhere in the mid nineteenth
century you know in an independent way
the score tells you a minimal number of
things consider a map right you can buy
several kinds of map you can google
several kinds of map one one kind of map
tells you just where everything is but
very little in between another map gives
a lot of details another map tells you
where the restaurants are and there are
all kinds of maps some napkin tell you
how crowded the roads are but a map
won't tell you actually how to drive may
tell you where it's going where to go it
doesn't tell you what to do when it
rains it mind tell you when that windy
road you might have elevation so I'm
gonna show you that it's gonna be a long
time to get from here to there even
though the two places look very close
together the score is a map it doesn't
say how to drive how well to drive how
to take the turns it doesn't how tell
you how to make the trip it only tells
you where you're going so the score is a
minimum number of instructions now
Tuscon Eenie after the Second World War
invented a marketing ploy that marketing
ploy was I only do what the composer's
intention who knows what the composer's
intention the cause was dead first of
all his or her intentions may not be the
most important he made misunderstood his
own music there are a lot of composers
who had strong ideas about their own
music which really were at odds it's
like writing a book is the best
interpreter of a novel by Tolstoy
Tolstoy himself no in fact it's much
more interesting to hear what other
people say about Tolstoy Dostoevsky cuz
nobody knows what the composer intended
and the composer can change his minds
for example Beethoven wrote a bunch of
symphonies
before 1817 in 1817 he fell in love with
a gizmo called the metronome so he said
well I'm gonna put metronome markings on
the compositions I wrote ten years ago
well he changed its mind Schumann
re-edited music he wrote when he was
younger and changed his mind about it
so intention is not a stable thing maybe
he thought this way about it later he
thought another way so putting a piece
of music on the stage is always about
intention of the interpreter it's never
really about an honest historical
representation of what the composer
intended that's a marketing ploy
the first is you have to know what you
want to say most important thing in
music as in everything else is having a
point of view
knowing the text and having an argument
so you're gonna play Hamlet you know
he's gonna turn them into cranky
Midwestern or gonna turn them into a
kind of New Age adolescent you're gonna
turn them into a disappointed former
evangelical you know choirboy I mean
whatever you gonna turn him into you
have to have a point of view about the
meaning of the text and the meaning of
the role the second thing is you have to
have the technical capacity without
speaking just with your hands to realize
that intention so it's read by the
musicians conducting is an international
language which means a good conductor
can go anyplace in the world get on a
podium not say a word and give it
downbeat and conduct a rehearsal or
performance and get what he or she wants
done done do you have to have the
technical capacity in your hands your
eyes and your body to communicate how
you want it to go and the third thing is
you have to actually have to be a
persuasive person you have to win the
respect and the affection of the players
in front of you they have to say this
person isn't wasting my time musicians
are very highly trained and intelligent
people and they sit in orchestras where
their individuality often is suppressed
you know they really can play their
instruments and here's this person up
there often incompetent a narcissist an
arrogant person telling them what to do
and their attitudes wait a minute
I can do that better you know it's as if
you know in a religion you had a bishop
conducting a bunch of priests well the
priests think I should be the bishop or
you're a rabbi giving this speech and
their rabbis in the audience all the
rabbi's think well I should be up there
talking so you're always dealing with
people who are competent sometimes maybe
more competent than you in certain
respects so why should they listen to
you you know why should we listen to the
president the United States even though
we elect
him you know somebody says I'm smarter
than the president says why should I
listen to him I know more about foreign
policy in the president Arthur watch I
listen to him so his or her powers of
persuasion are terribly important and
that leadership function to win the
affection and respect not only affection
many conductors because there's a
tension between players and conductors
go overboard a Leonard Bernstein's early
in his career want everybody to call him
by his first name now call him maestro
mr. Bernstein Lenny you know he was
friendly with everybody because he
wanted to break that barrier
you can go overboard in that as well
curry too much popularity but you have
to also demand and gain respect
challenging team conduct is the thing
you're working on now because all the
anxiety about getting up on stage and
doing it is located in that one piece so
the piece you're learning you know is is
always the uppermost your mind the other
two very important challenging things in
conducting our new music so music it's
never been played music that doesn't
have a reputation music that no it's
heard before so the question is what do
you make of it you're sort of the first
person to put it on stage and is the
first person to put it on stage the
question becomes how do you give this
piece its best shot it best chance its
best chance when it is maybe the first
performance or the first Lawrence in a
long time a revival and the third
probably most challenging one is a very
well known piece recently I did for
example with Don Upshaw here in New York
the fourth significance of Mahler with
the bard conservatory orchestra and uh
was a challenge only because it was a
young Orchestra very gifted young
musicians with a great soloist who's
done the piece many times but also
because we were doing in New York apiece
which has been done over and over and
over again and the question is the
burden of such a long tradition of
interpretation is a very heavy one so
either you give in to it or you try to
break it and if you break it you can
make enemies you can anger people
because most people come to a halt with
well-known repertory already in their
ear they've listened the same record
over and over and over and over again
they don't know that there's actually a
little book a printed notated book that
has the music so it's really like Hamlet
so you look at Hamlet you read Hamlet
I read Hamlet we can have a discussion
for days about what you think amel is
about what I think is Hamlet about but
if the only thing we had was a video of
Jack Nicholson playing Hamlet you know
then somebody else shows up you know
Leonard
Caprio plays Hamlet suddenly we're
comparing John Gould feel-good and
Leonardo DiCaprio we're not talking
about Shakespeare anymore you know
because in our minds eye we have a
mental picture of John Gielgud as Hamlet
so I'm offended by Leonardo DiCaprio you
know I I don't like it because I have in
my ear somebody else's voice
so most people come to a concert with
their favorite recording or two
recordings of very famous works so if
you do it differently you can anger them
for the audience member who realizes
that there's no standard interpretation
there's no right interpretation there
are different interpretations none has
better or worse and that you could
respond differently to the same work in
different ways you would want to hear it
differently I don't wanna hear it the
same way but in the classical music
business because of recording people get
used to hearing at the same way it gets
slower then it gets faster they're used
to a certain tempo and they're used it
because they've listened to it they've
learned it by repetition not by learning
the text but by having in their ear in a
way imprinted one version of it and that
audience is very hard